five time Pro Bowler one of the best
defensive players in the game from the
Carolina Panthers courtesy of Gatorade
good to see you Luke Kuechly how are you
bud good how are you I'm doing I am
doing fine so what do you think of this
matchup Super Bowl 50 - I think it'll be
it's gonna be exciting you know we've
had the opportunity to play against both
these teams and they're both they both
have different things going for him I
think you know what I think separates
Philly an offense is their ability to
run the ball they've got a really good
offensive line
they got Zach Ertz who's kind of like
Greg sure a guy they can get open and I
think Nick Foles doesn't get enough
credit for what he's been able to do
right so now you obviously know what it
takes to play in a game like this right
the big game like this when you have a
bunch of guys on Philadelphia many of
whom who have not been in that game what
would you what advice would you give
them when they get on that field in this
spot to play a big game like that well
hopefully the whole the whole week they
tried to keep the routine as similar as
possible to what they do back in Philly
you know whether it's your film study or
what you do during the week but when you
get to the stadium you got to realize
that there's gonna be a lot going on
there's gonna be when I was out there I
was warming up before a game and there's
a Kevin Durant and and usher was out
there and the people you're there's just
gonna be more surrounding the field
during the game the energy of the games
gonna be different but I think you got
to really do a good job of controlling
the emotions and and getting out there
and just playing the game and kind of
putting that all aside it's gonna be
difficult to do but gotta concentrate on
playing cuz that's what's important yeah
looky here on the Rich Eisen show and
you have played against Brady yeah you
have played against him
is there something Chris brockman you'd
like to get off your chest about the
Carolina no because he's a piece of
patriot fan do you know where this one
is this going back to 2013 yes yes it is
and I think I think why did you hold
Gronkowski win the game I think I might
have got away with
I said that we played a man and I held
him and I didn't mean to it wasn't on
purpose but I think I think I got away
with one there yes it does and you know
what I don't know I think I'm over it
yeah I think you should be over they've
had a good past come over you were
definitely not open no I'm more not over
it because with buddy play five years
ago he's the holding on to when you
bleep Blakeman showed up as a referee
AFC Championship game he'd lost his
marbles oh because but that wasn't cleat
clean had nothing to do with that call
his backyard right as the final say-so
is so is that the way to cover Gronk
obviously I know you're a defensive
player with the tons of skills but I
mean what what is the the style of play
required to cover that guy it's
difficult because he's he's so big he's
able to position like say you know it
doesn't matter how close you are to him
yes because if you're right on him and
he reaches that arm out that ball is
gonna go exactly where it needs to be
Brady's gonna put it like if it needs to
go on his hand it's gonna go on his hand
he's going his chest it's gonna go on
his chest he's able to he kind of has
that that tony gonzalez to him where
he's gonna run up he's gonna create
space with his body he's gonna box you
out the ball's gonna be right there
hasn't Matt and Tony did for so long and
that's what these guys do up in New
England so well all right yeah so it's
the Brady Gronk comedy I think he just
understands all right if all I got to do
is get me between I got to get between
the ball and the other guy and he's so
good at doing that and they run routes
that are conducive to doing that well
looky here in the Rich Eisen show we had
the aforementioned Greg Olson your dick
in that chair yesterday yes had a nice
conversation didn't we did and we also
you know one of the things I brought up
was the hits on Gronk the hit on Kelsey
yeah that knocked both of them out of
their respective playoff games do you
think those hits were dirty honestly I
didn't I didn't see the the Kelsey one I
saw the replay of the Gronk one I don't
I don't think guys are ever trying to be
dirty I just think when you're trying to
go up and and separate a ball from
somebody you know it you got to try to
hit him and stuff happens so fast guys
are ducking and so you know you guys go
after the ball and then they see you
come in
there they're trying to cover up and
sometimes you just make contact with
with the head area and you know I don't
think I think 95% of the guys in this in
this league aren't out there to try to
hurt people but sometimes those plays
happen where you can get hit in the head
and it's nobody wants it in the league
doesn't want it but it's sometimes it
happens well obviously it happens to you
yeah the delivering hit yeah now is
there anything based on the concussions
that you have incurred of your career
that is similar the hits were similar
the most similar I think I think when
when those guys liked those receivers go
up and get the ball they don't always
get to see it they don't always get to
see where the hits come from as a
linebacker I think a majority of the
time you know what you're hitting and
you know sometimes you're gonna get hit
by other guys but I think for the most
time on defense you know where you're
gonna get hit but on the offensive guys
it's hard because they get there to go
get the ball and they're concentrating
the ball and guys are coming from
everywhere so it's difficult Luke
Kuechly here on the Rich Eisen show and
I got to tell you this is my 15th Super
Bowl that I've been fortunate to cover
through this show and obviously the NFL
Network coming into being in 2003 been
to tons of games Thursday Night Football
the scared most scared I've ever been
was that Thursday night game we're
getting carted off I watched you carted
off their emotions took over you and we
thought that you knew you were having a
concussion and thus had that emotional
response but then after I've read up on
concussions that the emotional responses
brought on by the concussion is that
what happened yeah I think you know I
kind of did the same thing and you read
up on stuff and they're all they're all
very different and not everyone everyone
reacts differently in and obviously you
know I reacted differently to this one
versus that one and it's so one of the
situations I think that's why it scares
people so much is because there's no
good way to to measure it and examine it
and make sure your back is if you know I
always I always say if you break your
arm you can x-rayed and see this is
where you broke it and we either gonna
plate it or we're gonna put a cast on it
and then four weeks later we're gonna
x-ray it again and see how it is with
the concussion you can't really you
can't really do that and I think that's
where the the scare factor comes in a
little bit what are your loved ones tell
you they just want me to be all right
you know if I never played football
again they'd be happy
they wouldn't we yeah I mean well they
wouldn't know that that not that's the
wrong way to say I think if I never
played again they'd be ok with it but if
they want me to be healthy first of all
because I understand that you know the
brain is very important you want to
learn live a long healthy life so if if
I decided to stop playing football I
think they'd be very supportive of us so
why do you keep doing it I love playing
football I love the guys in the team I
love being around the game but I
wouldn't it's been what I've been doing
since I was a little kid and I trust the
doctors and the people we have around
that I've talked to about it I'm trying
to do everything I can that make sure
I'll get anymore a couple more minutes
here with luque here on the Rich Eisen
show tell the Cardinals about their new
head coach yes Steve Wilkes man I I love
that dude he's gonna be he's gonna be
great we're gonna miss him he's got
great energy he's fun to be around a
Phillipa room and obviously he
understands the X's and O's a football
put a good staff together but I think
what what separates him is his
connection with the guys and his ability
to connect with guys and learn about
guys and I mean the example that you
know when he got the job that we had a
group threat of probably 25 guys whether
it was it was you know I was on there
Thomas is on there peanut was on there
Roman Harper was on there and just a
bunch of guys that we had played with or
he had coach or he had been around that
we're all congratulating him and wishing
him best of luck and I don't know if
that happens everywhere but it's a good
track record if you start with peanut
and Roman guys that have been around for
a long time all the way up to the
younger guys they really loved him so
this bottle that you have in the corner
of my desk right here right by the MVP
trophy that's going to be handed out on
Sunday night G organic what is this what
is the organic part about this whole
yeah so I think what what Gator is
looking to do is is talk about you know
all some of their product lines other
than the normal Gator you know the fruit
punch and the lemon-lime and they got
the g2 out there and I think what they
want people to understand is that
Gatorades got different lines for for
different people and it's got seven
ingredients there's less in the bottle
and it still provides the same hydration
factors as a normal Gator it's just an
organic gorgeous version of it okay neat
I'd love to drive yeah I love you in a
world
well is it certainly since its it's free
for the moment right did you just you're
gonna leave it here or is that you want
I guess that's pretty weak of me to say
something like that who do you think's
winning this game man I think it's I
think it's her
against the Patriots you know what
they've been able to do and for an
extended period of time I think it's
hard to go against against New England
but we played both of them and I think
Phillies Phillies really good on defense
they Fletcher Cox as a stud I'm not I'm
not sure last time I tried to make a
prediction I blew it so I think it's
hard to go into the Patriots would you
blow what I you know in Seattle when
Seattle played New England no Denver
okay in 13 I thought I thought Denver
and sorted everybody come on hey so did
everybody the Seattle defense came to
play they did well I mean that first
that second snap that sailed straight
those guys played well that those guys
do a good job part of the reason why
that snap sale by Peyton Manning's head
was in New Jersey the crowd noise
Seattle fans they're great were every
raisi
they were absolutely everywhere but
you've but you've you've quieted them
before hey no we went up there we played
some games against there Greg made a big
a big catch that's what that's when I
thought okay this team's got a shot he
made the Superbowl that was a big win
for us you know what to go up there it's
a it's a fun place to play a game it's
loud up there but uh you know luckily
for us we got two home games and and our
fans are equally as good so we're
excited there will be at home you are
one the route for sir thank you for
coming on
absolutely show again is believe second
or third time you've been on one of our
Super Bowl shows you're welcome any time
Lou thank you very much brew Johnny
so check things out with Gatorade G
organic care of Luke Kuechly can follow
them on Twitter at Luke Kuechly so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience